what's good everyone has it going happy
Monday Persia here and today is the
two-year anniversary of God of War the
one from 2018 obviously if you can count
two years I can barely do so but yeah so
that's what we're playing today um to be
honest I really really loved this game
but it's been a minute and I feel like I
need to reorient myself but I did beat
it this is you know I'm exploring the
realms now I have a like a file started
very early on new game+ but I figured
you know let's try some post game things
like hunting for the Valkyries I
definitely fought the Valkyries totally
backwards the first time around so I
have to one remember how many I have
left and see if we can get them all
today on the streams so yeah thank you
and welcome and what's up Brandon what
is up stephen richie in the chat yeah
osmond the brown dog hello hi happy
Monday I hope you guys had a great
weekend mmm yeah drink some water stay
hydrated and yeah I missed to this game
though for real I remember when I first
played it I do not know what to expect
cuz I hadn't really tried the older god
of war games that's kind of the cool
thing about all these new iterations of
games
I'm not wearing black I know I know I'm
actually wearing my good vibes sweater
good vibes because it's Monday and I
feel like you know some good vibes are
in order um so yeah I remember playing
this before and it was really getting
crazy but I did upgrade all my stuff
everything is gold right now all that
shiny gold what's good Eddie what's good
superhuman Mitchell station probably
said all
names wrong me on night howdy how's it
goin but yeah I had to work all week
long
oh man I hope you get a break soon where
was I at in this game let's see I
definitely want to find some Valkyries
all right I have 104 in Midgard so I've
three here I got the one in alpha all
time I'll time there's an undiscovered
one so there is probably one in Helheim
Helheim is crazy
cuz they got all that that crazy stuff
the poison stuff oh yeah look so I
haven't discovered her yet but she's
over there oof I bet you she's crazy
I got the one in in Moose Musel I'm oh
my god these names these names but yeah
what is it ah I got that one really
early actually and I felt like that
should have been one of the last ones
but maybe I did it backwards I don't
know I think I have one here too okay
alright so nifflheim so that's like what
five
[Music]
three four five all right we got to try
to get all five of these Valkyries right
now right so most of them are here in
mid garden let's see let's see I'm
really curious to see if they're gonna
have any is like a expansion to this
especially for the other gates that you
can't unlock in the little terminal
thing where am I going I'm wandering
around aimlessly I have an objective oh
let's look at the map who have I not
defeated yet does it tell me which one I
did defeat
alright let's try this one over here yes
objective nice some names are harder
than phosphates and for real hello Missy
how's it going happy Monday
playing some God of War Oh men I kind of
went hopefully I'll run into some like
minions so I can warm up and remember
what I'm doing but this games so fun
this is it's so fun I love it and my son
my son here he's powered up top in the
boat I like I like swimming around in
the boat cuz he knows the guy the head
guy I don't know his name I don't
remember
nobody always tells the stories which is
great all right already got whatever was
yeah Amir says I love this game so much
same I'll go slow so we can listen to
his story you know at this point
shreya was married ordered and orden
frankly would have traded up for a
sufficiently strong lead
Grimm's palace man this games so
peaceful no it's gonna be over
wait where am I going did I go to write
the story I guess I do have to know
maybe okay all right the wrong way but
it's fine oops
I didn't do that one first
she cast a powerful spell before that of
Jotunheim word no means the point of the
story even he calls him Ned I don't feel
so bad for not remembering his name yeah
these are just some postgame things you
can do like side quests but you know
there's a bunch of Valkyries and you
gotta kind of defeat them to set them
free
hold up where am I I think I'm going the
right way yes okay we are definitely
definitely pulling up
this is gonna be Han load because it's
been a while since I've played but we
got this we got this I believe also oh
snap there we go isn't it your birthday
Brandon happy birthday bro uh alright oh
are you telling me I could have just
taken that it's okay I wanted to take a
boat ride a nice peaceful boat ride
before it gets stressful alright so this
is my mic attack this is the heavy
switch my weapons
what else guard aim right okay there's
more stuff I'm just starting to remember
[Music]
okay let's see probably in there
planning your demise oh yeah this is her
house actually haven't tried going to
her house since then seriously I'll
never be what I once was but yeah
where is I'm going the right way right
I'm right here I felt like I was a lot
closer to it before
hmm how do I get there I'm doing a
little bit a little bit of exploring
here first could be for oh my gosh I
kind of forgot how to do stuff don't
mind me
what the heck well man after playing
doom I'm like all disoriented on the
wall of clams now so bright and pretty
out here though okay alright you do that
you do that
like we're going further away
it's so pretty though where is this
gotta be but who gets I was up here
before
clearly I knocked this down
all right feel like
this a tunnel over here done we'll be
here
you know what you might have to go there
so maybe the entrance
sorry guys I'm still orienting myself
but at least it's super beautiful it's
nice to look at
oh boy oh boy what is that
Oh
cuckoo I think I'm set on runes and
stuff for now though
Oh what is oh yeah oh dang I can't get
distracted right now all right hold up I
can fast shovel to some of these areas
no it's just kids let's fast travel here
we got to go back down you know now
right now now right now I can't get
distracted I'm already lost we climbed
up out the ground where is it how am I
so lost already
how am I so lost
oh my I seriously don't know where
can you not get back down there huh no
all right dude
do I just not see it no I'm so lost
[Music]
let's just go this way been for a bit
might be able to circle around
I don't think I've come back here since
I've gotten them some of my new ability
is actually oh my goodness I cannot
believe how lost I am right now holy
crap I can't believe it a lot say it
right now
oh here we go I remember we jumped over
the log he said he was gonna go Scout oh
okay I thought I was never gonna make it
back goes a bash travel oh man if
getting there is bad and I can only
imagine how this first fight with the
Valkyries is gonna go
I hope I'm overpowered I hope I really
did do the last one first on accident
now where is the this thing
oh yeah it's down low it's down though
thank you Maps whoo I know persistent he
was persistent Mitchie
alright I'm ready now now that we've
found our way oh just kidding
so killin their dessert is yeah thank
goodness I thought I was never ever
gonna find it yeah awesome that makes
life easier although I did enjoy the
boat ride I really did just keep running
around until it loads up move it kid got
places to be
yeah
oh boy yeah this is gonna be let's
remember together shall we guys my full
life already I have abilities right l1
so I think I remember I have to get my
abilities off right away
hold up I need to remember some of these
I know this is gonna be boring for a
second but I need to remember how to do
this
why won't it let me scroll through my
skills oh oh whoa no let's go back oh
there oh okay gotcha game press are we
I'm not using those oh my close combat
where has all my skills oh yeah they
were selective that's right okay
okay okay yeah so r1 uh oh there she is
there she is ah hey Jessica
what's good welcome back welcome back
oh my god okay I have to mentally
prepare myself for this we got this
let's do it
Monday motivation energy and the check
yo KITT get over here what you doing you
better not okay wings off all right this
is not gonna be pretty but I guarantee
you guys we're gonna get there we're
gonna get there oh shoot
oh gosh oh gosh oh no oh no remember
oh yeah this is not good oh shoot oh
that was it that was it
oh my gosh okay that's not good okay
this is just uh you know me remembering
a little bit Oh
I was super far away I with it it's fine
I'm still remembering I should may use
that ban to be honest oh my gosh okay
I've been playing too many other games
ah it's fine it's fine
I already told you guys it was going to
be ugly
cuz I I know I know everyone I - those
are my attack buttons oh my goodness
kingdom hearts is ruined me I'm such a
button masher okay let's do it
Oh
where's my shelters
Oh what is my dog again is it square
squirt no what is it oh it's it's ant
it's okay oh yeah
ah
nope No
oh man oh man it's fine that was a
little bit better than before
wait what's my power up it's like r3
right that's like oh shoot
oh she dodged it ah okay okay I'm room
it's coming back to me slowly it's
coming back to me slowly Dodge was she's
flying yay
you bet you ready right all right dang
might okay and then and then what is
okay up about okay I couldn't remember
how to switch his arrows all right and
then this is my quick turn okay okay all
right I'm feeling much better about this
now Oh
[Music]
ah
No No
[Music]
no yes yes my son Oh Oh
whoo
Oh No
oh no oh no my son you know what my son
help me
oh no did I cancel my oh wait I'm so
alive I'm still alive yes yes my son
let's go oh oh yeah we're angry now
satisfying
oh no she beste how do I can I run oh
okay it's fine I got her I got her
it's so satisfying man this game is fun
yo my son jumped off my back son midair
oh I got you girl I got you girl why
were you in this physical form oh man
okay
we are getting there now you guys
getting in the groove get in and a girl
a little bit
all right one down for him where to go
that's right I'm supposed to start those
battles with like a full range already
oh that thing is good you know oh I got
a new epic and I know it sounds like the
team was out a lot sooner than two years
ago let's get someone change them get
them from the duty the Queen can't say
for sure a lot we should ask more of
them if of course he don't mind that
distraction he's always throwing shade
oh he's throwing shade what's down here
oh it's just to be
it's just dead in
okay all right so where is the next one
we got her so how do we get here oh
where is the other one
Oh okay let's fast travel to this game
all right on to the next one
increase the audio is the audio super
low there you go let me know that's
better
[Music]
is that better it's the audio louder
okay oh yeah it's coming back to me now
you guys oh yeah man I remember I was
just starting to unlock really cool
stuff
wait is this where hold up where am I
going
not swear it's that away let's run a
little bit more
yeah I'm running away from it it's over
here in here I get lost so easily in
this game there's so many places to go
oh I feel like this is the long lean no
there's a fast travel move it sorry
sorry my child you fought well in the
last battle
he did that I remember I heard that fly
zip right by our ears
yo do player what's good welcome back um
yeah I guess I wasn't supposed
where am I going lower it's somewhere
around here I'm sure we're very close to
it I am Chinese bad travel I just keep
getting lost so I'm trying to go back to
the portals there it is yeah I walked
right by it of course of course
like I can't jump off until it's totally
stops do you know Kratos he's careful I
think this is on like normal actually
it's not unlike any crazy yeah it's not
on any crazy modes this is my first god
of war game so I wanted to you know take
it easy but not easy but you know normal
I feel like normal is like a good
baseline in most games all right on to
the next Valkyrie there we go
not go in there wet light like that but
is it picking up the game okay no I
already broke that
she's up here somewhere
the way
is it really that far it's on the side
of the cliff over here on the left side
of the tree somewhere over here
okay let's have to go down this way
hi getting there is half the battle
oh it has to be over here yeah in this
big ol scary cave let's go let's go
you've got to play this one I would
highly recommend I think this one's
really good it's really fun once you get
there like a grass with the combos and
everything it's like super fun yeah and
it's only 20 bucks right now that's the
other crazy theme because I was playing
it on PS now but it wasn't on PS now
like they took it off I think in January
or something so I already had to
download it though so I just paid for it
and then boom am I going the right way
not going the right way I'm walking
completely away from it no
[Music]
I mean I feel like the combat is really
rewarding and really cool it looks
really good I love the story is the
story the story sent me on a
rollercoaster of emotions all right
where is this Valkyrie
just like in the mountain somewhere
oh man I forgot how to do this one the
fire the key please what's in here
though
okie doke who dis okay find some other
stuff even though that's not what I want
to find where is she all right hold up
might be able to climb down this wall
hmm
must be another side of this I can go
down there has to be
somewhere over there inside the mountain
probably know what what what what do you
hunt about tell them you my child
wow that's a sight no magic I brought
him back to the bed my bad my bad dude
or I brought him back to his body I
remember that scene that's so funny
all right I don't think I can find it
through that way we're gonna have to
keep looking around
hmm
it has to be here somewhere also I had
to have run into it right it's on my map
they only show up if you run into I'm
right or no I have any other phone yes
over here
I have this one okay these these are the
last two in Midgard I just have to
figure out how to get there
my rope here again how's the idea here
this looks like I could climb down there
but I can't all right let's go this way
again
maybe there's I remember there being a
scene where I climbed around this tower
though like what's that what's that
right there
all right I guess my next best bet is to
just go through the mountain right left
of the trail sorry there's also like a
45 second stream delay down the mountain
left of the trail left on the path to
the other door over here oh man
stream delay does not make this fun
I'll try to walk slowly until I can get
there left of the path of the other door
if you're talking about this door I'm
not sure
I'm trying to find the valkyries guys
give me a moment I just really don't
know if this is the right way
wait lowers my map 1140 1104 I mean
let's see okay it's definitely lower I
guess
wrong way no yeah I am going the wrong
way can I get to it from out here like
if I go down in two rounds
it's like I should just go to the other
realms where I really know where they
are the one in a knuckle hein though I
think is like surrounded by poison gas
I'm like not looking forward to that one
at all all right we're going back to the
trail lower section of the mountain you
have some distance before you get there
slowly walk the only issue with the
stream delay is I don't know when to
stop because you're like stop and I'm
already somewhere else forty-five
seconds later alright I'm gonna go back
to lower section of the mountain oh so
you know that's the right way then right
through that side of the mountain am i
right am i right
or over here definitely not over here
I keep Freddie and do it did I go
through the mountain you know what or
through the mountain on the other side
by the portal alright alright let's go
back up honestly I think the last time I
was playing I definitely got stuck here
to the left here
so it looks like you could climb down
somewhere
yes through the mountain left that
through these directions okay got it
through the mountain and keep going down
boom those are the directions and we're
sticking to them
I just want to fight the Valkyries
already why are they so hidden I'm just
trying to save them I'm just trying to
save their souls we out we were going
the right way the first time we out
just happy
wine the mountain thanks so realistic
they make you go dude
climbing the ladder just no like quick
sliding or anything like that
shiny stuff
it's like I've definitely been here
already cuz everything is ransacked all
right now it feels like we're getting
closer to Valkyrie territory where oh I
think you already did whatever that was
supposed to be actually oh I think it
bat one oh I know what I was supposed to
be with that I'll do it on the way back
wait where am I going am I still going
to my way I think so I see my little
Czech marker
decreasing slowly way thank you thank
you for that I was like no way this is
not a dead end
what's up shop dude is she in there she
in his body in his belly
no hold up sir another way down
oh my goodnes I thought I was making it
somewhere climb down 70 oh my goodness
oh my goodness oh yeah hmm at Reyes come
be lost with me I feel like this is a
dead end
oh here we go and like a balcony
Valkyrie only oh my goodness how do I
get there I'm huntin I told you guys we
were gonna be huntin I'm huntin
my goodness I'm already very
directionally challenged
I have no navigation okay so the shop
dude was over there the chest was over
there but I didn't see anything else so
let's try this thing and you shoot that
thing
oops I felt like whatever was up here I
thought I did it already but
yeah I don't think that was in any
relation to what I was supposed to be
doing oh my goodness you guys I don't
know where I'm going I can't find this
valkyrie over here I'm about to just go
to another realm and get the ones over
there since I know where they are and
maybe come back to this one later
nothing in here I am so it's just
they're just like something random in
there yeah oh snap oh snap wait hold up
another path like this might be the one
I hope I just want to fight wait was
this it did I just walk in a circle Oh
psych what the heck I am so lost oh yeah
we did go down here how did I come out
the other side oh my goodness okay
wisely oh yeah okay I'm 100% lost yep
yep it's official it is official I don't
know where I got is in the area where
the big hook was and the movable block
big big hook in the MU block where's the
big hook it's been a hot minute since I
played so I don't remember where
everything was clearly I cannot I don't
think I could have I don't think I was
able to find her before either which is
why I can't find her now
big hook where's the big hook Sarah hook
over here big hook is a big dead dragon
but wait what was that I saw that I saw
a promise we are indeed chillin the
music's really good in this game yeah
okay definitely nothing over here and
now I feel like I'm stuck because the
only other gateway is over there
and that one I don't know if I can find
her either all right I say we go back to
the teleporter we go back to another
realm where there's literally like one
Valkyrie and you just walk straight
forward so it's before the dragon Birds
so this room up here I suppose I'll keep
an eye out for a big hook though
needs to butt
just keep going up oh no my going in
circles again I'm truly truly 100% lost
it also doesn't help that I did most of
this stuff already so I have no visual
guide of like where I actually am
there's a little hook right there that's
the hook here's a key all right we're
just gonna go back to the middle of
mid-grade I'm we're gonna teleport over
to somewhere else to another realm where
at least I know that they're actually
over there so we don't waste any more
time because I just wanna play that
first Valkyrie fight was just like
dipping the toes back in the water along
the left side of this path right here
that I'm on this snowy path I know you
guys were mentioning a path before but I
couldn't tell which path you guys were
talking about the Memphis is like a maze
and I'm feeling all right back to the
teleporter and then you said something
will promise to climb to the left left
trail so if I walk out of the toilet
teleporter here this left trail okay
yeah this doesn't like I was saying
earlier this looked like there would be
something I see that over there but that
just goes up to the top wait maybe
that's where I should climb down right
Yeah right so hold up
that was over here right
[Music]
or no was that not it this is this is
yeah we were over there right
oh my lord
Shayne said never played this game but
always wanted to I would highly
recommend it it's 20 bucks right now on
ps4 yeah that's definitely where I was
but I couldn't I couldn't walk it if
that's what you were speaking about what
is he looking at
go there and move the screen I'm telling
you we could just go to the teleporter
go to another can't gets her from her
yeah this I was thinking I was like I
don't think I can take this path it's
definitely moving the screen
yeah that path is not we're just gonna
go to another realm can I lose me no
there there for sure
shouldn't be this hard to get to the
other ones I don't think we'll probably
for sure have a live stream for
cyberpunk
I'm sure all right yeah we're just gonna
go to a different realm
we're still valkyrie hunting i wish i
just couldn't find that one and i don't
want to waste more time and there's a
huge stream delay so i'll hopefully
advise on the directions they're like
really hard to follow but it's all good
please load my gateway yeah there is yes
of them says I love this game
so do I it's pretty great alright let's
go
they released any DLC yet not that I
know of but okay so I got the one in elf
I'm I haven't discovered this one yet
but it's just straight ahead shouldn't
be that difficult
oh and there's uh there's a gateway here
yeah so let's go there let's go to
Helheim shall we
I don't know it's always been that way
and I choose not to change the settings
too much because I don't want to break
anything
so I just leave it be so yeah
it's so like the ambiance it's so nice
I love using this portal actually
one of the realms is like Asgard I think
but you can't travel there it's like
blocks or whatever I was like I hope one
day I hope one day we'll be able to go
there oh snap doomsayers already asking
where the demons at I don't know what
they're technically called demons or not
I ran smash travel over there all of the
fast travel okay let's go watch this one
be like so crazy difficult oh I was just
ramping up to with that first fight
action saying I should have bought one
of those other things one of those
stones ah I might have to go back to the
shop after this if I can't do it because
I know he used the stone great
all right it's okay let's do this
oh man
Oh
ah
No
Oh oh my gosh I am not using the correct
things right now
hold up I spent too much time searching
hi oh my oh no oh no oh you need the
relaxer is it oh okay it's our one no no
stop it
oh okay I was hoping that was thunder
but I wasn't sure
oh she dodged it oh gosh
[Music]
oh my goodness no way
she got me oh no honestly I wasn't
expecting to go that far
cuz I I realized I was under-resourced
right there um but yeah I feel like I
already figured out her pattern it's
fine wait I need to go back to the store
though real quick real real quick I
can't do this without at least one
resurrection stone and locking on yeah
you're right that's what if she starts
doing all that stuff she's like it makes
me lose my loss on I think it's all
great let me go buy some some resources
I knew I was under resourced right there
we have we good though that sucks it
took me forever to find another Valkyrie
because I was just gearing up
what's good bro skis
I like when they're both at the shop
thank you and so anything I can buy that
actually won't just like no like I just
like a look yes that's all there is
leave me alone all right here we go we
back at it a little bit of help I can
remember it's r1 and r2 for my impacts
x2 Dodge I'm like trying to press square
to dodge pressing circle to attack I'm
like what am i doing alright we're back
we're here to free you all right ready
my son oh shoot
No
no oh I tried I tried okay
oh no babbit
okay I think I just have to bluff that
I have invincibility - ah it hurts know
it oh it's fine
it's fine Oh No oh no I - straight back
instead of okay it's fine I'm gonna have
my rage meter without the rage ah
yes I'm fine my child
no she's scooped me up she stood me up
Oh
[Music]
this is dangerous I'm gonna die no oh no
I couldn't
I that's when I should have already read
her okay we almost had it we all decided
it that was fun though I think I still
keep my stone I am alright I think so I
think so it's fine
we got this
[Music]
we're in there now
Oh Oh No
see I tried the r3 right there but she
just too fast she was too fast
[Music]
definitely dodged death
oh boy oh boy
[Music]
you need the relax girl oh oh I'm just
kidding Oh No
no way I dodge that come on whoa yo girl
no no what am i doing oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yes yeah get angry get angry
Oh get over it Oh oh crap
Oh No Dutch Dutch dodge again Dutch
Schumer x oh she's really no I dodged
into it not like this
okay she got she got me it's fine it's
fine
sorry sorry it's Reyes you're on your
own boy you're on your own boy all right
it's fine it's fine we've got this I'm
still making some execution errors here
and I need to be more mindful of my
cooldown meters
where is she Hey
[Music]
oh my goodness I hooked her and she came
over to stomp me out oh no oh no oh
[Music]
okay all right the patterns downloaded I
just gotta try to capitalize every time
yeah oh she got me she mixed me up
sneaky oh okay okay I'm getting too
crazy now hold up
I
yes all right we got this
oh yeah we oh yeah we shut it out
no no what's that one oh oh my god I did
it again come on
oh whoa oh my gosh okay I have the stone
it's fine it's fine
she's a goner
Oh No
oh I'm so dumb I got too confident and
she stomped me out all right it's fine
this is definitely the run she was close
to dying it's fine
I'm getting I'm playing no more games
okay all right we clear too far
yo that was that was cheap
now that was cheap oh shoot
oh oh no I was mashing it this what am i
doing
I am moving slow you're right don't
expose me like this don't expose me like
this knocking over here girl I know oh
I'm dodging with the wrong button okay
we can no okay okay that was just a
series of unfortunate circumstances this
is definitely there definitely the run
because I'm not going into this with
full rage already and there is no rage
crystals here that really helps the
whole situation but I don't want to
waste I am going and fighting minions
now no way I dodged that I swear
it's so cool
and the slow motion like oh my
no I wasn't far away no she is working
me right now
okay
oh my god I knew it I knew it
okay okay okay
so she snuck out of it all right let me
try not to mess this up
she's still
live live okay okay
go beat her up oh no oh oh I'm Cheyenne
my son ah no crap my weapon changes Oh
No Oh Chris
oh my goodness Oh No yeah tell me about
it
that was all bad that was all that I
think I have a rune that like if I keep
beating you up I get health back unless
I took it off but that's kind of what
I'm counting on for when I get her stuck
there oh all right I still I just wish I
had full rage meter right now
look
okay
[Music]
no okay how CCB's me
she is mobile
oh my gosh all right we got this you got
this one I don't even think I need the
rage meter this one if I miss all of
that then I might no okay fine
oh my god oh my god okay she's hurting
[Music]
she's super okay
Oh see we got this one in the bag no no
oh she's really good sneaking up
okay about this it's easy street
oh wait did I just know oh yeah if I can
oh my god why can't I pull my axe out
I'm my stone right my stuff we're good
I was trying to pull my axe out that
whole time I don't know where she is
oh no shoot tonight where's my axe oh my
goodness gracious
that's all I wanted to do that whole
time and I could not get my axe all
right it was almost a wrap but it's okay
we kept it together holy smokes
I couldn't find my axe Oh are we gonna
have to fight the Queen Lance I must I
must find my gosh that was kratos just
squared up for real that was crazy
where did my axe go
I know she was stomping all over me the
disrespect is responsible head high when
I saw her last she was different change
that was fun as hell though lates at the
grand power the Vox rain increasing
strength and runic you just came to say
goodbye
that sounds good too
she wants to be
I was definitely panicking definitely
she is responsible the balconies must be
Asgardian steel yes yes okay
terrifying but we did it here ah let's
keep it Lucy I actually kept some of my
resurrection meter also which will help
me for the next fight hopefully yeah oh
my gosh I felt like I spent so much time
looking for that other Valkyrie that
it's only fair I go fight another one
one that I know where that where it is
so it would be quick I wanted to try to
get all five but those two in Midgard
I'm gonna have to go look up how to find
them and then save it for another stream
three-year anniversary no I hope I don't
wait a whole nother year before I
believe it would be really sad
okay let's go to the next realm god this
game is so fun though
alright where else I already got the one
here there's one here see this one this
one is all up in the mist so it's like
just finding that one it's gonna hurt
I'll time I already did down one but I
guess that's the one that we can
guarantee you fine so let's go let's go
- oh honey we out which about praise do
I have left the ones I have left are IB
nifflheim which is when we're going to
see now and then there's two in the to
in mid grade that I can't find oh no I
press triangle
which takes us to Midgard sorry all my
button configurations I had just seen
triangle in the top right without
reading and I was a site that must be it
what a bummer well
check out this whole animation real
quick I really hope that this valkyries
just not super hard to get to because
that would be really unfortunate I mean
I know I have to go through the guests
but hopefully I get to speed run through
and find it
wait what Nerdist Christman it wasn't a
different spot I thought it was gonna be
in the same spot
but I hope you guys are having fun and
chillin thanks for hanging out with me
today playing some God of War feels nice
I mean any excuse to play this game to
be honest
any excuse I'm down
let us in we want to fight the Valkyries
go go go all right we up
I might have to fight some minions along
the way but that might be good actually
because oh man you know what I do
remember about this stage there's like
so many traps and ways to die
most definitely need another
resurrection stone cuz I'm not gonna
survive without it that's gonna have to
wait the other game two gates two days
ago
enjoy awesome alright let's go and try
and get this Val Green yeah she's she's
way over there but I'm gonna try our
best
it's like if you die out here - you like
don't get your stuff back or something
either so you're actually enjoying of
all these workshop yeah yeah you think
all right I remember there being traps
and stuff but oh no I'm gonna try to
speed run my way over
mmm see all why straight punch that dog
in the face
[Music]
ah
I miss
[Music]
alright that was all and open this to
get some more missed echoes that's what
they're called okay okay uh holds up
real quick I need to check them out so I
need to keep running oh my goodness is
it up here I don't think it's up here
those walls and stuff oh this is where
the rift air stuff is yeah no thanks
oh crap do I have to fight those guys
again alright so it's off to the left
yeah I knew I was like I think they
respawn again
[Music]
so epic
ow yeah take that okay so let me grab
these it's this way off to the left left
right left okay
left right left so this way first oh my
gosh watch me get squished okay oh there
was a mystical box in there and then
right right so oh shoot
Oh No
oh no Jill they're all slimy and gross
oh my gosh yeah
oh I did not wanna do that put that away
I'm glad you can cancel it because my
gosh I can
we're not even gonna make it to this
Valkyrie
oh she's so annoying I hate I hate her
thank goodness
oh oh oh she lives actually didn't
realize what was going on ah believe my
son tonight / thank you must get the
mist echoes thank goodness
hopefully there's more right here yes
please
echo it up I go out I don't want to be
in front of that thing those all the oh
my gosh would which way did I come in
from I think I came in from that way I'm
gonna run oh shoot okay I am NOT gonna
make it to the bathroom no okay miss
echoes just echoes and then you said
left right okay I'm just gonna get this
oh we're hurting for some echoes you
guys we are hurt we are in deep in the
crypts right now yes give me all the
echos yes replenish okay okay here we go
there she is and that the fighter in
this stat is insane I'm not gonna make
it all right
oh my god oh my gosh oh oh I'm frozen
No
I thought I was gonna have a spot to
like re up my echoes but nah they
straight up we're like dies all right on
that note I'm gonna have to wrap it up
because I I thought it was gonna like
let me go to a point where I could like
read up the Miss echoes and then get a
fighter but they were like nah get good
and beater but we'll be here all day if
I do that and unfortunately we're out of
time already it's so soon actually went
by really fast even though I spent most
of it lost but thank you guys so much
for tuning in and hanging out happy
Monday I hope you guys have a great week
and don't forget every weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific time we are live we're playing
all kinds of things and I hope you enjoy
it so have a good one we'll see you
tomorrow and take care peace out see ya
later
you